hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
a dog a cat and a mouse are at point a
on triangle abc
all three simultaneously run along
triangle abc first covering a b
then bc and finally ca
the dog moves at speed 12 on a b
10 on bc and 15 on ca
the cat moves at speed 15 on a b
15 on bc and 10 on ca
the mouse moves at speed 10 on a b 20 on
bc and 12 on ca
if all three finish at a at the same
time
what is the measure of angle abc
i thank zaki for suggesting this problem
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so to solve this seemingly impossible
problem we need to think backwards how
can we find the measure of angle abc
recall that a triangle's angles are
determined by the relative lengths of
its sides so let's solve for the ratio
of the sides
we'll let a b be equal to 1 and let's
solve for bc which we'll denote as x and
c a which we'll denote as y
the dog moves at speed 12 on a b 10 on
bc and 15 on ca
what's the total time it takes to run
around the triangle
that time t will be equal to a b over 12
plus bc over 10 plus ca over 15.
now we've supposed that a b is equal to
1
bc is equal to x and c a is equal to y
let's write a similar equation for the
cat to do this we have to remember that
it takes the same time for them to move
around the triangle so we can use the
same time value of t
so the equation for the cat is that t is
equal to 1 over 15 plus x over 15 plus y
over 10.
we finally have a similar equation for
the mouse
we substitute in its speeds along the
different sides
we now have three equations that are all
equal to t
to make this a little more manageable
let's multiply each equation by 60 to
get rid of the denominators
we now have three equations that are all
equal to 60t
therefore we can set these three
equations equal to each other
let's solve this system of equations
we'll first consider the first two
equations
we can move the x terms to the left the
y terms to the right and we end up that
one plus two x is equal to two y
this simplifies to be one half plus x is
equal to y
now let's look at the second and third
equations
we again simplify this and we get x plus
y is equal to two
we then substitute in that y is equal to
one-half plus x
we can then get a single equation in one
variable x which we can solve that x is
equal to three-fourths we substitute
that back and solve that y is equal to
five over four
so we've solved for the relative sizes
if a b is equal to one
but i still don't know the angle abc
let's scale all sides by a common ratio
of four
so a b will be equal to four bc will be
equal to three and c a is equal to five
we now have a familiar right triangle
this is a 3 4 5 right triangle where a b
is equal to 4 bc is equal to 3 and c a
is equal to 5.
furthermore angle abc is a right angle
therefore its measure is 90 degrees and
like magic we have solved for the angle
measure
incredible
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]